One of the things that happens in the
old testament is Israel struggles up to
state and empire status six times
its struggles out of the chaos,
up to empire status,
and then it gets corrupt.
It loses the way it isn't.
Balancing things between chaos and order
properly that the kings get arrogant.
It's so to the people and they
forget their relationship with God.
That's another way of thinking about it.
And then a profit comes up and says,
you aren't paying enough attention
to the widows and the orphans.
You better look out because
that displeases God and the
Israelites who are stiff
necked and arrogant think
what's God going to do to us,
which is not a very wise way of thinking.
And so they don't take the steps necessary
to rectify their deviation from the
proper path.
And they get absolutely flattened
and the consequences of that last for
generations,
like seven generations.
And then they struggle their way up to
something approximating empire status
again.
And exactly the same thing happens.
They forget and they collapse.
And there's six stories like
that in the Old Testament.
It's all deep documented by
a man named Northrop Frye,
who is a Canadian literary critic who
wrote a couple of books on the Bible,
one called the great code and the
other called words with power,
which I would highly recommend.
It's an analysis of the
Bible as literature.
Brilliant.
For those of you who might be
interested in union thinking,
Fry's thinking is a nice adjunct.
So all right,
so,
so that's the nature of the
world order chaos and order.
And your goal is to keep those,
the relationship between
those two things optimized.
And you do that by
doing what's meaningful,
not what's expedient.
That's rule six and you ensure that you
have the world construed property by
following rule number eight,
which is tell the truth,
or at least don't lie.
You don't want to pathologize the instinct
that orients you in the world and you
will pathologize it by
engaging in habitual deceit.
And the reason you do that is
when you practice something,
you build structures that specialize in
that and then they run automatically.
So if you're living a lie,
which is a very common
thing for people to do,
then you're building
neurological mechanisms that
view the world through that
lie.
And once they're built,
they're you and good luck unbuilding them.
It's very,
very difficult.
That's in part what happens to people
who are addicted by the way they build
mechanisms of search,
neurological structures that are focused
on the drug and those systems are alive
and all they want is the drug and they're,
they're not,
it's not psychological.
Exactly.
It's psychophysiological don't build
structures of cognition predicated on
deception because you will pay for it.
And so if you're going to guide your
life with the orientation of the instinct
of meaning,
then you have to be very careful with
what you say and write and think.
Because every time you say
or write or think something,
you build a little neurological structure
that's specialized for that and it
participates in this parsing of the world.
So all right,
chaos and order.
Then you can say the
order orders a hierarchy.
Okay,
so here's the next question.
Next two questions is order a hierarchy.
And then a subsidiary question would be,
if order is a hierarchy,
what's,
well,
either what is at the top of the hierarchy
or what should be at the top of the
hierarchy instead of hierarchies,
a structure value.
So that's the question is what
should be of all come at value.
Okay,
so now we're going to take
that apart a little bit.
The first thing I would say
is order is not a hierarchy.
Order is a set of hierarchies.
That's a different thing.
So,
uh.